- I feel like y'all are both
wearing colors in my shirt.
- In your shirt and your background.
- But I should have worn my solid number.
It's great to see you again.
So have you met Jessica?
- [Susan] We just did.
- Okay. Okay.
Yes.
- So you go way back?
- Yeah.
- Way back like this couch.
- So it's crazy.
This is the final season.
This is it.
- It's so nuts.
- Are you super emotional about it?
'Cause not many shows are lucky
enough to get this kind of
I mean, it's such a huge
epic, pop culture moment.
This show.
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
- Like to be a part of
something like that is massive.
So is it kind of so sad?
- Like you're literally
getting me two days
after we just wrapped,
So it's just.
- Oh no.
(Susan laughing)
- I'm like, oh,
- That's hard.
- You're like, no,
- Are you OK?
- I'm OK,
- Do you need a hug?
- I think so.
(susan laughing)
- That's so weird.
Cause you've seen these
people every day for years.
- Yeah. For six years.
And it really is like a ripping away
of people who have become
your family, in so many ways.
And so it was very surreal,
but the one thing I told
myself that I'm gonna do.
Is every day for the
past last month of it,
just be present and just take it in
because then at least I can
say, I remember I was there.
I didn't like leave my body
and try to push it outta my mind.
It's not happening. Whatever,
you know, it's happening.
Let it be the long goodbye
and just like experience it.
And I thought maybe then I wouldn't cry
and then did not work.
(everyone laughing)
- And then. You cry.
- And then I cry.
- I saw this video.
It's the whole cast and it went viral.
So I wanna show everybody this.
So what was going on here?
This was impromptu, look at Sterling.
(women laughing)
- This was us on a break.
So we had all this time,
this was a 18 hour day.
And we were there from six
o'clock... Look at the booties
- Look at the booties.
(audience laughing)
- We were there from,
I think I got there at eight
o'clock in the morning.
I remember leaving just after midnight.
We were all there shooting the
Kate second wedding to Phil.
A wonderful person who runs our social,
Sarah Wareheim came and she
always has ideas for us to do.
She was coming to Sterling with something.
And I think between her and Sterling,
they came up with this idea
and he was asking me about music choices.
And I was like, you should do something
that people would play at a barbecue.
Everybody can dance.
- Yeah.
- And he came up with the Wobble
and then he taught everybody.
(spectator shouting)
And you know, I was
- Except for Mr. Hartley.
He's just chilling on the couch
- [Susan] No. Mr. Hartley.
Well, he knows his position.
He knows like.
- He's like
(loud laugh)
- I know my lane, I'm gonna be here.
- He's like, does he not dance.
Is this what it is?
- No. Ma'am he just,
- No ma'am.
(kelly clapping and laughing)
- Does he not do it well?
did he not do that well?
- He did it well.
- I love it. He is just on the phone.
- Yeah
- Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
- He's was like.
- He's just making deals
- From those dancing. I love it.
I was like, that just
means he don't dance.
(Jessica laughing)
- And that's what we do on our break.
That was like a break.
- I love that.
- It's the way to just kind
of get through the day.
- Well, we're celebrating mama's all week.
So you play a cool mama.
- Oh cool.
- Have you
learned anything about
yourself by playing a mom?
- It probably.
And you guys can tell me.
'Cause I'm not a mama.
I played one on TV.
- Yeah.
- Patience. Right? Like
some kind of like, patience!
- Look, you're not so like, I'll tell you.
You have it. Okay. It's there.
It's right in front of you.
- Right.
- And then it flees.
- It goes away
At some moment. Yeah.
(Jessica laughing)
- And then enter rage.
(Susan laughing)
Or how many times do I,
You have a bedtime
- Right?
- It's gonna happen every 24 hours.
I don't know why we're having this.
So yeah. Patience is good for a minute.
- Yeah. Right. For a minute.
- And then you,
So, I learned nothing then.
Cause that was the one thing I took away.
(Kelly laughing)
- That's right.
- No, but I'll tell you.
If you can have the patience of job,
if you can hold that down,
- Mm
- And relax, it's much
easier they respond,
but sometimes you feel crazy?
- Yeah.
- Cause you're like, we
have had this conversation.
I don't even know how many times.
- I don't know if you do this.
Maybe you do this on TV.
- Okay.
- When I'm so frustrated
I lose my patience
and my kids turn away from me and I go.
(freaking out silently)
(Susan laughing)
- Yeah..
- Yeah.
- You're like.
- Okay.
- Okay baby, come over here
let's talk about it again.
They turn their backs
and I do crazy stuff like that.
- Oh, so you don't snatch 'em.
- I've snatched
(indistinct)
- But, sometimes.
you don't,
- You can't snatch anymore.
- Is that's the thing.
Listen, I'm not a mom.
I said I play one on TV.
(audience applauding)
- Here's the thing
- You can do.
- I'm just trying to figure
it out, they helping me out.
- Here's the thing.
(Susan laughing)
(audience applauding)
- Here's the thing.
I think I have my mama saying,
"I don't have to snatch."
I have a tone and it's genie Taylor.
It's my mom's voice comes through me.
- Okay.
- Yes.
- I can feel it.
I leave my body.
She comes in there and
like all of a sudden,
I literally have said,
"You did not just walk away from me
while I'm talking to you."
And they just freeze.
- Yes. Like
(Susan laughing)
- You don't have to snatch anymore.
Just gotta figure out
that tone.
- The tone.
- Well, my mom had a look.
- With the eyes.
She didn't
- Even expend the energy.
She just gave you the
(stare face)
(audience laughing)
- Yeah. Yeah.
- You were like, let me
get everything together.
- That's terrifying.
I feel it.
- You felt that. Yeah.
- You're gonna be a great mom.
I mess with it.
(everyone laughing)
(audience applauding)
- It's a quiet moment though.
And it's the patience.
Those are man.
If you can nail those,
you are winning.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Susan] You're good.
- Everybody watched the final season
of "This Is Us."
Tuesdays right here on NBC
and catch the season finale May 24th.